einen schönen Abend wünschen und das
mitten in der Jahrhundertflut im Aartal
die Informationen aus der Nacht der
flugkatastrophe die werden jetzt immer
verheerender für diese beiden hier
Ministerpräsidentin von Rheinland-Pfalz
malo Dreyer und Ex Innenminister Roger
levents ja während den Menschen ihres
Bundeslandes das Wasser bis zum Hals
stand schreiben die beiden sich eifrig
SMS hin und her und schauen Sie mal was
da so steht 12 Nachrichten sind bekannt
Malu Dreyer um 21 Uhr 36 Uhr lieber
Roger ich bin morgen von sieben bis acht
bei einem Termin du kannst mich vorher
oder nachher erreichen Lebens antwortet
21:40 Uhr dann nach acht bis morgen die
nächsten zwei SMS wird diskutiert ob die
inzwischen zurückgetretene
Umweltministerin Anne Spiegel informiert
worden sei das weiße Lebens aber nicht
Unwissen in so einer Katastrophe Nacht
auf diese Unwissenheit reagiert malo
Dreier um 21 Uhr 44 mit okay schönen
Abend einen schönen Abend während ein
Polizei aber diese schlimmen Aufnahmen
macht aus dem Aartal diese Bilder die
wurden erst vor kurzem öffentliches sind
diese Szenen wegen denen sogar Events
als Innenminister von Rheinland-Pfalz
zurückgetreten ist
134 Menschen tot salut zerstörte
Landstriche Häuser und Existenzen alles
hinüber er hatte die Katastrophe über
Fotos aus dem Hubschrauber gesehen und
trotzdem nichts gemacht ja und mit dem
jetzt veröffentlichen SMS-Verkehr dürfte
es nun auch für Malu Dreyer eng werden
dieser Verlauf der legt ja nun nahe dass
die Landesregierung sich in der
flutnacht erstmal schlafen gelegt hat
keine Lagebesprechung kein
Krisenmanagement
Lebens am
4.10.2022 es gab kein belastbares
Lagebild auch auf den Videos sehen wir
keine eingestürzten Häuser wir sehen
einen treibenden PKW und wenige Gas und
Öltanks aus meiner Sicht sind keine
Toten hier dokumentiert legen Sie mir
das bitte nicht als Kälte aus
tja und das wir haben selber gesehen wo
man doch auf diesen Videos sehr deutlich
erkennen konnte wie dramatisch die Lage
war
[Musik]